women today a lot of you know feminists
and you know I'm not talking about the
OG feminists who fought for their right
to vote and the right to just work
respect I'm talking about modern day
feminism they don't need no man I'm a
boss babe like you know you know there's
a lot of a lot of uh information about
that about the tragic future of that
type of mindset where you're going to be
52 years old one day with a million
bucks in the bank and no one to share it
with and what you would have done
differently and I know women my age that
are in their early 40s that I'm like
girl you should have been married off
the streets 10 years ago girl and like
they're still out there so like how do
you have such a good grasp on the
masculine role the feminine role and do
you think girls your age fully grasp it
as well
um I feel like it is a a new way of
thinking obviously modern feminism is
different than the traditional feminist
uh definition feminism just means that
you know we want everyone to be equal
it's just named feminism because at the
time women were considered less than
um and we were just fighting for the
same rights so the right to vote um the
right to you know just you know be
considered a person as much as a man
um but as far as modern feminism where
we're instantly just going to like f men
I don't need a man women rule women rock
at the same time what they're doing is
fostering a hateful environment that is
also putting off men from the idea of
feminism or treating women with respect
because if these women are just being so
blatantly aggressive and just
generalizing men obviously the
appropriate response on behalf of all
men is to generalize women and
generalize women as you know gold
diggers as scumbags as women who who
um that women can't be trusted because
women just hate men or something like
that so obviously I feel like that this
is just like a code for how humans
interact with each other anyway there's
always supposed to be a mutual respect
and if you want to get anything done and
you want to have a proper discourse you
always got to do it with modern like
with a decent respect you know like in
debates when people get fueled by
emotions that's when respect is lost and
that's when ultimately like everything
you say just becomes a fallacy you're
attacking someone's character straw man
like whatever
um and that's just like you're not gonna
get anywhere with that in my opinion but
the way that I am able to manage my time
and be you know fulfill my role or at
least the role that I believe in because
everyone is entitled to differences of
opinion and that's what makes humans
amazing
um my role of a woman or at least the
role that I have given myself because
you know because of traditional feminism
I now have a choice to do the things
that I want to my choice is to be a good
partner to a man who has a traditional
job you know he goes in the morning and
he comes back in the evening and he's
exhausted I have a different job
um I'm an influencer so I I will go on
work trips and film like a whole bunch
of travel content because now my my
content isn't so much like the content
that you've like saw earlier it's more
travel Vlogs With A comedic take on the
things that I did at traveling so I'll
go traveling um if I can't take him then
I'll take an assistant if I can't take
an assistant I'll take one of my best
friends and we'll just record my
day-to-day life and then I'll go home
and I'll sit down it takes me a full day
to edit because I have like two weeks
worth of footage or a week worth of
footage and I make it look like one
cohesive day even reusing the same
makeup or using the same outfits just to
like you know keep the at least make the
story seem more genuine so if you like
that clip click right here to watch
another or if you want to watch the
entire saucecast click right here
foreign
[Music]